Oh next,
this class and the next,
uh,
class and a half are going to be about the end,
the fishers theory of the,
about Fisher's theory of present value and the interest rate.
Uh,
and then we're gonna move to uncertainty,
but I'm going to,
uh,
so we've up till now what we've done is we found out first how if you know the
whole economic system,
how to solve for equilibrium to figure out from the primitives of people's
tastes.
They're inpatients,
the technology of the economy,
how to figure out what the real rate of interest is provided there's no
uncertainty in the world and people can forecast what's going to happen later.
We found that once you've done that,
the price of every asset,
if people are rational and looking forward to the future,
the price of every asset is going to be the present value of the future payments
of the acid.
So if you think of the payments as real payments,
which is what fish are always recommended,
you discount by the real interest rate.
If you think of them as cash payments,
then you discount by the nominal interest rate.
So every asset corresponds to its present value of its dividends,
either discounted by the real rate or the nominal rate.
Now this thinking is surprisingly powerful and leads you to unexpected
conclusions and the the,
the uh,
so the,
the next class,
the next two classes is about that.
Mostly I'm going to talk about social security,
but I'm going to begin today by finishing off a subject we didn't quite get
through last time.
So you see,
if you realize that the price of every asset is just the present value of its
dividends and you also suppose that you know what the dividends are going to be
and what the future interest rates are going to be,
then it follows that you know what the price of the acid is going to be not just
today but next year and the year after and the year after that.
So your theory of asset pricing today,
which was based on the assumption that you can forecast the future necessarily
implies a theory of acid pricing in the future.
So you can tell something about how asset prices are going to change.
And of course you can also test the theory because the theory implicitly is
forecasting something about the future.
And if you,
and therefore you can test the theory.
So let's just take a couple examples that are in the notes.
So we said at the top,
if you can read it,
I hope it's not too small.
I,
uh,
want to move a little quickly so I could be writing on this and the board,
but if you can see it and you look at the top line,
it says that the present value of assets is just equal to the present.
The present value of assets is just equal to their future.
The present value,
the present value of the assets.
It's just a discount of,
of future dividends.
So maybe I'll start one line up actually in these notes.
Okay.
So if you look in the middle here,
the present value today,
suppose you have an acid.
Maybe I'm going to write on the board.
After all,
president,
family,
man,
I said,
suppose you know,
the dividends are going to be paying c one c two and maybe CT at the end.
Those are the dividends.
They're going to be paid.
And you can ask what the present value of the acid is today.
Pv,
uh,
today?
Zero.
Well,
Fisher would say,
if you think of these as nominal cash flows,
he would say the first,
what you need to do is you need to find out the price of Zeros.
So you'll recall that Fisher said that you could let pie won equal the price
today.
Okay.
Of $1 at time one.
And the price today pie a t equals the price today of $1 at time T.
Okay.
It's the price today
of $1 in the future.
These were the crucial prices that Fisher said that you should always look for.
He said that you can always find these prices.
Pie one through Pi Ti by deriving them from the yield curve.
So every morning everybody looks at the yield curve.
All financial analysts,
they look at the prices of bonds traded in the market.
You know,
the simplest form.
As you get a yield curve in the newspapers,
you deduced from the yield curve what these present values,
Pi one Pi tr and that allows you to price any acid like this one simply by
multiplying by Pi one pi two and at the end by Pi Ti.
Okay,
so that's,
that's step one.
But then step two we said was that once you've got these prices you can figure
out the forwards.
So the forwards,
okay
are going to be one plus it he so one plus it.
That's by definition a the interest
from tea
to t plus one that would be agreed today.
Okay.
He is not the interest rate that's going to prevail at time.
T it's the interest rate that people today at time zero would agree to pay
between time t and time t plus one.
So that of course has to just equal pi ti over Pied t plus one because everybody
today recognizes that the cost of a dollar time t his piety in the cost of a
dollar at time.
T plus one is probably people's one.
So the trade off between t and t plus one,
that's effectively what an interest rate does is a trades off money at one time
for another time.
It has to be this ratio.
So today people would agree on one plus it forward is the forward rate.
Now you add to that the assumption that everybody is perfect is certain about
future assume uh,
a complete con assume perfect forecasting.
Hey,
so I don't have to actually assume that people are right in their forecasting.
I have to assume that there are completely sure of their forecasting,
so they're completely sure of their forecasting.
Then everybody must force see that.
They think they're sure that the future interest rate that will prevail at time.
T is also equal to this number.
Okay.
So we can then write,
we write this price,
hello.
We can rewrite this price as one plus I zero word.
Okay.
That's uh,
instead of Pi to Pi two is just going to be one plus I zero forward times one
plus I one forward.
Right.
And T and time Pi t is just going to be one plus zero forward times one.
Plus I one forward dot,
dot,
dot times one plus I t minus one forward.
Okay.
Because the,
you know,
using the fact that the eye one plus it is the prod is Pi t divided by Pi t plus
one.
I just multiply,
you know,
pie one divided by Pi two times Pi two divided by Pi zero et cetera.
Uh,
are a py one divided by I multiply,
uh,
you know,
if I take Pi one divided by Pi zero times,
uh,
et Cetera,
I'm going to get exactly this formula.
So Pi Zero,
okay.
So I'm going to get exactly this formula so I can uh,
Pi zero is always one by the way.
So if I want to take Pi one,
it's just going to be one over one plus eyes zero f if I want to take pie to,
I can always take a,
I can always do this high to,
and so this is going to equal pie too.
So Pi two is going to be one over one.
Plus I have zero times one over one plus I have won it Cetera.
Pi Three if I wanted to do pi three I just multiply it by Pi three over pie too.
And so that's equal to one of one plus I f zero times one of one plus one times
one over one plus I have to.
So instead of multiplying by the pis,
I might as well take the product of the forwards.
It's exactly the same thing.
Okay.
So the present value has this simple formula,
but this is a formula that holds at every time key if you,
if you're totally confident of your predictions of the seas and of the future at
your interest rates or cause this is where we ended last time.
Basically with this formula,
the key that you had to use in the problem set was to realize if you're totally
confident now about the future,
you have to be totally confident about doing this calculation in the future.
So PV one is going to be basically the same calculation,
but just so what's going to happen at time one,
after you've gone down one year,
you finished with this interest rate and you're looking at everything,
um,
one year later.
So I might as well write the PV one here.
Okay,
that's going to equal c two let's put it a little bit lower.
PV One is going to equal the same c two as before,
but now you're a year later.
So it's just going to be one plus I f one k plus.
See if t and I,
I don't mean the one plus I have zero anymore.
One plus I f one times one plus I f t minus one.
Okay,
so it's exactly the same formula one year later and one year later you no longer
have to worry about the interest rate that time already passed.
So you just drop this at every time and you write the same formula.
Of course you drop see one because that's all finished.
So the price at time one is just what's left except you've chopped off the one
plus I am zero everywhere.
Okay,
so to write that the same way.
So P v zero,
I can write it the same way.
Equals
Pv zero equals what is going to equal the interest payment.
You get see one,
not the interest of the dividend.
You get the cash flow,
you get plus P v one
divided by one plus f zero
so why is that?
So this is a very important formula.
So why,
why is that?
Well,
it's approved by formula,
but another way of saying it is that right?
You know,
Pv zero when you,
when you get the acid at a time zero it gives you a cash flow at time one and
then of course looked at from the point of view of time one you've got all the
future cash flows,
but that's just what PV one is.
So basically the,
the,
the bond is going to give you a cash flow at time one and then the right to cash
flows in the future.
But this right,
the cash flows in the future at timeline is worth PV one.
So it's like you've got all this money at time one and so to get the value of
times here,
you have to discount it back again.
Okay.
So this is a very famous and important formula,
which I want to pause a second and think about.
Yeah.
So there's a controversy today called marking to market.
Okay.
Does anybody know what that controversy is about?
What is marking to market mean?
Yup.
Right,
right.
And,
okay,
so,
but you know that they've been relieved of this responsibility recently.
Well,
so they've been relieved of this responsibility lately.
Now why have they been relieved of it?
Because the thought was that the market was so panicked in the crisis that the
price that they could fetch by selling their things really had nothing to do
with the value.
Okay.
But so let's,
we're going to come back to whether that was a good idea that they,
you know,
Congress passed under tremendous pressure.
Um,
what is the point of marking to market?
So let's suppose that you really could anticipate the future and everybody was
right about it.
The market price then would really be PV zero today.
And it really wouldn't be PV one tomorrow.
Because if,
if the interest rates to actually turn out to be what everybody expects and
everybody's completely confident of their expectation,
then as we saw the prices would have to be this today and this tomorrow.
Otherwise there'd be an arbitrage.
You can make money for sure.
I think you could make money for sure.
So if you're marketing to market,
what are you going to mark as the profits?
Are you going to say the profit,
uh,
at time one is,
so what is profit?
Let's just,
if I had some room,
I'd put this somewhere.
How would you define,
um,
how would you define profit?
I'll get rid of this.
I think we've got this straight.
Okay.
So how would you define profit?
Time one what would you write?
So let's say that this isn't a bond.
It's a,
an investment.
You paid a bunch of money at time zero,
maybe PV zero and in the future your investment is going to pay off some money.
You know,
maybe it was a project you invested in,
maybe you,
you know,
you bought a bunch of stuff and you're selling it in the future and getting this
money.
Maybe you bought a bond which is paying these coupons,
whatever it is.
These are the cash flows of the project.
And now of course,
your investors are very curious.
In year one,
they want to know what profit is you have you made,
how are you doing?
So what's a number that you'd think of giving?
What's the first number you'd think of telling them?
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you might think of saying c of one.
That's the cash you've,
so all these people could tell it.
Say you've gotten see of one that's your,
that's your revenue.
And I'm assuming this cashflow is net of expenses.
So you could say here's your revenue you got at timelines one c of one is that
your profit?
If it were,
people would then look and they'd say,
well we got profit of c of one and we put an investment in of p of v zero.
So is that the a rate of return?
Is that my rate of return?
Yup.
Okay.
So,
okay.
See you have won this exactly right.
I'm going to repeat what he said,
but I'm going to take longer to say it.
Um,
this idea of writing c of one over p of v zero is actually what many people try
to say is their profit but is a bad number for for profit.
Now if you weren't,
if in period one you stopped marking to market and who had no idea,
you didn't have to report this number,
Pv one,
I mean you didn't know what it was or you didn't have to report it,
what else could you report?
But see one over PV zero as the prophet.
So marking to market you see is intimately connected to how you report profit.
So if you don't mark to market,
you don't know,
you don't have to declare what the value of the assets are that are left.
All you would do when you declare when need to describe your profits as you'd
say c one and people would of course in their heads,
in fact they wouldn't do it in their heads.
You tell them,
you know,
our rate of return was see one over PV zero.
But why might that be a very misleading number?
Well,
his point is it could well be that sea of one is a very high number.
You've got a lot of cash flow this period.
But he said it may turn out that PV one is a terrible number.
So you s you know,
you may got a lot of cash flow,
but there's nothing left going forward.
So,
uh,
he would,
he,
he doesn't think that's a very good measure of profit.
So he's suggesting why not report,
um,
profit as c of one?
Yeah.
Plus P v one minus P v zero.
Okay.
Now suppose you did that.
Um,
so he's saying,
look,
you got a certain amount of cash,
but the assets that you had also changed value and you ought to include that in
your profit.
So what if you did that?
What would your rate of return B
and Suppose Pv zero was NPV one recalculated as this and so you divided this by
Pv zero,
what would that equal?
What,
what number would I get if I did that?
I can't hear what
somebody speak up.
Yes.
Okay.
This would just be I f zero and you'd get the rate of return that you're
expecting to get.
Now why do I know that's I have zero cause I'll mow.
I multiplied by Pv zero to this side.
Okay.
Then I moved that Pv zero to the other side.
Might Cause we one plus I zero F P v zero.
Then I divide by one plus I have zero and put it down here and that's this
formula.
Okay,
so that is what you would get.
I have zero and you see that's what you should expect to get.
Cause you haven't done anything great.
You've got a cash flow,
you've got these cash flows at the beginning you paid a fair price for them and
next period everybody forecast that the values we're going to go to PV one and
so it can't be that you're,
you know this was an investment you made,
you put your money in,
you bought this bond,
you could sell the bond.
Now at time one after having obtained the cashflows,
it better be that your rate of return is the market interest rate of return.
Otherwise there'd be some arbitrage.
And in fact it is.
So if you can compute all the present values properly,
the only fair thing to do,
this is not a great investment.
Even if c one is a huge amount of money,
it's only huge because PV one is a low amount of money because it has to be that
the profit every period,
the rate of profit is exactly equal to the interest rate because everything's
always priced at its present value.
Okay?
So it's a,
a simple concept which somehow,
um,
takes a long time to grasp.
It just seems to people that,
you know,
here's the money that's coming in.
That's the cash you can count in your hands.
You've got it in your hands.
That's the number you should talk about is profit.
But of course,
if the money coming into your hands,
you know,
there's this other hidden thing,
the stuff that you own is suddenly fallen in value compared to what it was
before.
You're really not putting the firm in any better position than it was before.
You just earned your normal rate of return.
So it may well be that.
Um,
so it's,
you can see why to give a fair description of how people are doing.
The law was written,
evolved to the point where people were forced not to just say c of one.
They are forced to declare mark to market and add PV,
one minus PV zero to their profit to get a real rate of return to get an action
to get a,
a,
a more um,
revealing rate of return.
Okay.
And so what happened in the crisis is this PV one became such a horribly low
number that if you plug that in to this formula,
you'd get PV.
One is a,
is a really low number compared PV zero,
you get a giant negative here.
It would look like the rate of return,
the rate of,
you know,
return was terrible.
Everyone would panic and think the firms had fallen apart.
So especially the banks who are the ones who didn't want to do this.
And so congress didn't want the public to be panicked.
So it's simply said,
okay,
forget about it.
We're going to not hold you to writing PV one anymore because you know,
we can't count anybody.
Figuring out what it is.
And so you don't have to tell us that.
You just have to tell us this,
which happens to be a good number for the banks.
But that doesn't mean the banks are actually doing well because the assets they
hold had been collapsing and value.
Yeah.
Yes.
Right.
It's what exactly what it says and that's what does happen.
So you always talking about the price x dividend and stuff like that.
Precisely that.
So if a firm pays a bigger than usual dividends,
if a gigantic,
if it's suddenly decides it's going to pay itself a gigantic dividend,
then the price of the firm is going to go down.
Exactly.
Okay.
Because there's less value in the firm.
You've paid it out here instead of keeping it into the firm.
Okay.
So this is a very simple idea,
but it's very easy to get confused about it.
Are there any questions about it?
Okay,
so let's do an example of it.
The most basic example of it is the premium,
the premium bond.
We talked about this before,
the premium bonds.
So let's say you have PV zero equals no five divided by one plus 10 plus five
divided by one plus 10 plus.
Maybe this was exactly the problem set.
I can't remember.
Five divided by one plus 10.
Okay,
so in other words,
the interest rate,
I did that wrong.
Squared and t,
so the interest rate,
so the forwards,
in other words,
one plus I f little t equals one plus 10 for all tea.
So all the Fords or 10% the bond is paying.
I can't remember which one I did.
Let's,
let's do the,
uh,
let's do 20 here and then make it a premium bond.
So it's paying 20.
Okay.
So what's going to be the,
the,
the price of the bond?
Well,
in the first period it looks like you get this incredible profit.
The interest rate is 10% you've paid some present value and you've made 20.
You've made a number much bigger.
So the price of this thing,
by the way,
did it,
what was the homework problem?
What was,
what were the numbers?
Yeah,
what was the interest rate?
Yeah.
Did somebody do the homework?
I did assign a homework on a premium bond.
Right?
What were the interest rate was 5% and the coupon was 10 was that what it was?
Or
what?
What was it?
What was the homework problem?
Eight and six.
Okay,
so this was 8% might as well do this one.
You can t six here?
Yup.
6%
okay.
And this one was a hundred was eight.
Okay.
So what was the price?
PV Zero.
What was Pv zero
you've done this homework problem,
right?
Okay.
Does anyone remember what number they got?
Ben,
do you remember the number right?
No,
I'm counting on my trusty class here to provide me all the numbers yet.
It was,
what
was that?
What?
It was one oh 8.4 that's all
this was the price.
Just one to 8.4
okay.
Um,
okay,
so one oh 8.4 right?
It's okay.
That's all high price.
So it's way above par.
This is a Ron that's worth much more than a hundred.
Why?
Because the interest rate is 6% but the coupon is eight so this is called a
premium bond.
So if you look at the first year,
the rate of return on the first year is eight over 108.4 now is that,
um,
more than 6% it's way more than 6% eight over 108.4 is,
you know,
seven.
Uh,
that's,
you know,
it's,
it's way more than a 6% cause 7% of this is going to be,
um,
you know,
7% of this is going to be less the next,
so it's more than 7% so this is greater than 7%.
Okay.
And so it's bigger,
it's certainly bigger than 6%.
So it sure looks like at the end of the first year,
like this bond was in a spot.
That's the kind of calls that you use to get,
you still sometimes do get them,
you know,
if a,
if you're a wealthy person and you actually answered calls like this,
which you don't of course,
but you can get some cold call from a salesperson saying,
we've got to fund and look how well it's doing on this much investment.
Last year we got payments of $8 that's more than 7% and you look,
everybody can see the interest rate's only 6% we did better than 7% we're doing
great.
Why don't you invest in our fund?
But actually what the,
what the salesman hasn't told you is that the value of his assets has gone down.
Okay?
So the present value of Pv one must be less than PV zero.
Because we know from this formula that hold the form of the right up here,
that 6% is going to be the cash flow over PV zero,
which is more than 7% plus this difference and this difference,
therefore it's going to have to be negative.
So what he didn't tell you was that the fund lost value even though the first
payment was better than 6% the market rate of interest.
Okay?
So that's the uh,
okay.
So that's the first example.
Now let's um,
let's do another example.
Suppose you have a,
uh,
suppose you can see if I can write on this board.
So there's a famous trade called the carry trade.
Now suppose the forwards,
suppose one plus I f zero is 2% sort of like now the one year yield and one plus
I f t is you know,
5% for t greater than one.
Okay.
So if you have a one year bond,
it's going to pay,
well.
Let's say it's 2% and this is equal to one plus.
Can you see this or it's this appearing.
So let's make the first,
uh,
to have them be 2% and this is for t greater than or equal to three.
Okay,
so the interest rate is 2% and then it's going to jump to 5%.
All right?
So if you have a two year bond,
a two year treasury at two year bond might pay,
um,
two and 102 and the present value of this equals a hundred
present value of the two year bond.
Okay.
But now maybe you've got a longer bond that's a five year bond,
which pays coupons,
you know,
a four,
four,
this is a five year mine.
Okay.
And maybe it's price is close to a hundred actually,
I haven't worked out the numbers.
So you're going to have to do that.
The next problem set.
So is it possible,
so I'll ask it this way,
is it possible for this coupon to be higher four,
four,
four and yet still have a present value of 100 then this one,
which is two in a hundred to,
could you have a higher coupon and yet the same present value of a hundred on a
longer bond than on a shorter bond.
Okay.
How could this bond have a higher coupon and still for the same price as this
bond?
Yup.
You're losing money on the assets.
You've been principal value people to get it in a later period.
Okay,
so the point is you're discounting the first two payments by 2% a year,
but you're discounting these payments by 5% a year.
So these things are going to be much worse than they look.
And so even though the fours are all better,
this hundred you know,
it's four,
four,
four plus a hundred that hundred not to mention,
these three last fours are getting discounted by a lot.
So that hundred four is going to be worth less than a hundred back back.
You know it's going to be worth less.
Okay.
So that's why these things are going to go down a lot more than you'd think
they're going to be worth less than a hundred so even those,
even the least things are better than the 2% rate of this bond is great at the
beginning.
But those poorly thereafter,
because at the beginning it's paying,
you know,
4% when the interest rate is 2% but later it's paying for is when the interest
rate is 5% so clearly you could have some situation like that.
So what's the carry trade?
The carry trade is you buy the long bond.
Okay.
And sell short.
That's
the short bond.
So the,
they'll let the uh,
the lower maturity,
too many shorts,
the lower maturity
mine.
Okay.
This is the,
this is the,
you know,
let's say five year and two year by the five year.
Yeah,
I five year bond and sell short the two year.
Okay.
Can you selling short and short?
The word sell short is different from the word short bonds.
So you buy the five year bond and you sell the short,
the two year bond,
they both cost you a hundred so what's happening at the beginning?
You're making $4 and you're only having to pay $2 it looks like you're making a
profit for nothing,
right?
So that's the carry trade.
You buy long bonds with a high rate of interest.
You sell short bonds with low coupons and it looks like you're making a profit.
But in fact,
what's really happening?
So just repeat what you were saying before,
but now in this context,
what's really happening?
Right?
So the long bond,
you got a cashflow of for the first year you had to pay too because you sold the
two years short,
right?
So you're up $2 but the thing that you owe now at the end of the first year,
since the interest rate is 2% the next interest rate is 2% the two year bond is
still worth a hundred so your net,
your negative position is still worth a hundred but this positive possession now
these four forest and forest,
it looks worse than it did before because you've moved up the yield curve.
Instead of having to 2% years,
you only got one 2% year before you shift into the five percent's which is worse
and worse.
So what's going to happen is you're going to get a positive cash flow at the
beginning.
It looks like positive profits right at the beginning.
Okay?
That c one is,
you know,
the net,
see one,
it looks really good,
but right after that the value of your assets is going to plummet compared to
your liabilities because now all of a sudden you're discounting this at 5% and
this thing is still,
you know,
it's only got one year left where the interest rate is still 2% and the rest of
this is discounted at 5% so starting to go down in value.
Okay.
So all right,
so what,
um,
so if you didn't have to mark to market,
what would you do
if you didn't have to declare to the world what your present value of your
remaining assets are?
Cause you could say,
oh,
it's so hard to figure out,
I don't know what the stuff is worth the present value of what's going forward.
I just know,
you know,
the cash that's coming in this carry trade would look like a really good trade,
wasn't it?
And a lot of people would do it because then they would look,
they could,
the public would think that they're doing really well because they're getting
positive value.
But in the future,
if that's positive value they're getting,
it's just disguising losses that are happening in their portfolios going
forward.
So any questions about that?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I want you to explain it.
So you see that if this side didn't calculate the numbers,
it would've been better to do actual numbers.
Uh,
if we do four,
four,
four at 5% interest,
or maybe I can do a,
uh,
let's just do a real number.
Well,
let's just do the one over here.
So this one is,
um,
uh,
no,
I can't do it because we got 2% and then 4% okay.
So it take a minute to do it on excel.
And you've seen how great I am doing those on the fly.
So the point is that you agree that this payment for is bigger than two.
Okay?
So the first year,
if you buy this bond and you sell that bond,
you're going to have a positive net $2.
However,
it's perfectly possible for this whole bond at the beginning to be worth a
hundred the same as this bond at the beginning.
Now how could that be?
Well,
the payments for is bigger than two.
So how could this whole thing have a higher present value than this thing?
It has to be that starting at period one,
the present value of this five year bond,
let's call it this.
Okay.
And period one minus the present value of the two year bond starting in period
one has to be what?
Yeah.
If this whole thing,
if this present value of the five year bond,
this is the five year bond at times zero equals a hundred and that's exactly the
same as this present value at times zero of the two year bond that equals a
hundred so the present value from the beginning of this thing is the same as the
present value of this thing from the beginning.
How could this thing have value a hundred well,
it's because it makes lots of high coupon payments,
but the interest rate is going to jump up in the future to 5% so you're
discounting all these future clash falls at a big number.
So all these things present valued could well equal 100
okay,
so this could be a hundred in this.
Could be a hundred even though this is paying off more at the beginning.
Then this thing is okay,
but then what does that form now that we just wrote down over there,
what is this formula?
Tell us where was this formula that I wrote down?
This formula over here tells us if the present values of two instruments,
I see,
I'd wrote it for one bond,
but if you take two bonds,
okay,
with the same present value,
one of which has a higher cash flow in the first period than the other.
Then that form on your tells you the bond with the higher cashflow at the
beginning has to have a bigger drop and the present value than the other bond.
Otherwise you can't get them both equal to the same hundred so this bond and
this bond have the same present value of a hundred because this payment is
bigger than this payment,
but the present values are the same.
100 it has to be that starting from this point on this bond is worth less than
that bond.
So what happened you,
you go long this bond,
you short that bond.
You say to the world,
the Ha,
I've made $2,
I'm a genius.
And then you hide from them.
You might hide from them.
He didn't have to tell them,
they wouldn't know that the present value of the bond,
you're long going forward is actually lower by $2 from the present value going
forward of the,
this is right after this period.
The present value starting at this point of this bond going forward has actually
dropped $2 below the present value of this bond going forward
and it has to have dropped cause otherwise the present values wouldn't be the
same.
Okay,
so it's as you say it much more simply.
If you take two bonds with the same present value,
you could well have that situation where they have the same present value
because one of the bonds pays a lot of stuff early and terrible stuff late.
It's okay.
So in the beginning it looks like this bond is paying you more money than the
other bond,
but since they had the same present value,
it must mean that this bond is going to pay you more money at the tail.
Then this bond is,
that's why they had the same present value.
So if one of them gets ahead at the beginning,
it has to be,
it's going to fall behind the rest of the time.
So this one got ahead at the beginning.
It has to fall behind the rest of the time.
That's hard to see because it looks this bond,
you know it's paying a coupon that's always bigger than that bond.
So you,
you,
you look,
it's easy to lose track of the fact that this bond,
because it's coupon is higher than this bond.
How could it possibly ever fall below this bond?
Well,
it falls below because it's longer and the cash flows towards the end of it are
being discounted by an interest rate because everybody knows the interest rate's
going to go up.
Okay.
And remember we saw last time the yield curve,
the yield curve.
Remember today's yield curve,
you know,
is practically zero now because the government's held at zero,
it's going to go way up to 4% or something,
you know,
in a couple of years.
Okay.
So that's the yield curve today.
So everybody knows the interest rates are really low now and again,
you get much higher leader.
So what it means is that every long bond that's being issued now is going to be
issued with a higher coupon than the short bonds.
And if you go long the long bond and short the short bond,
you're going to make money at the beginning,
but lose it back later.
But if you don't have to report mark to market,
you don't have to say the value of what's left over.
The public's just going to see that you're making money at the beginning.
It's clear now.
Okay.
Any other questions about this?
So this is a lot of this is going on right now.
MMM.
Okay.
So let's do one more application of this.
Let's try,
let's explain how mortgages work.
One more,
uh,
idea.
Okay.
Since,
since the present value is equal to the cash flow plus the present value at one
times that given this formula,
that tells you one more thing.
Very important idea.
How do you compute,
present value zero.
Well,
the way we've always computed present value at zero is to do this calculation,
this long calculation discounting all the future cash flows.
But this formula tells you that there's actually a more efficient way of
calculating it by backward induction.
If I knew what the present value was a time one,
then I could get the present value at time zero just by this formula.
I'd add the present value of time one to the cash at time one and discounted.
So in fact,
I don't have to.
Now,
I don't know the present value at time one,
but if I go to the end,
you know,
at the end of the time,
I know the present value of the bond is zero.
There's nothing coming up later at time.
T minus one I know the present value is very easy to calculate.
It's CFT divided by one plus cy,
F t minus one.
So I can go backwards.
By present value and Compute,
I can do backward induction.
So that's the word I want to describe,
which is going to play a very important role in the future class.
Backward induction.
It says,
if this formula's correct,
then a good way to do the computation is by working backwards from the end.
Don't just blindly take the present value.
If you blindly take the present,
all you've got is PV zero.
If I calculate by backward induction,
I start to the end and say,
what would PV t minus one bead?
That's a really simple thing.
Then I can very simply find out what PV t minus two is,
et cetera.
Back to the beginning.
I do basically the same calculations without having to take powers of a,
it's a shorter calculation because here I've got exponents of,
of uh,
of,
uh,
you know,
of interest rates multiplying each other.
So it's actually a shorter calculation.
And on top of that,
I get much more information cause now I've,
I've calculated out what the present value is going to be at every time period.
So much more efficient way of calculating things is to do by backward induction
because it also tells me more.
It tells me what the future path of a,
of the bond is going to be.
So let's just see how that works.
And an example that I hope I worked out properly before,
whereas I did it last year.
But what's,
I assume I did it right.
So
let's take a mortgage if you can see this.
So this is something you have in your notes.
So there's,
there's a mortgage.
Now how does a
uh,
all right,
well pay no attention to that.
So let's just say that.
Um,
oh no.
Why did this happen?
Um,
let's say that the payment is,
uh,
eight.
Yeah.
And uh,
eight.
Okay,
so I've made payments of eight everywhere.
so this is so here.
So I,
I hope I haven't screwed though.
So here's the mortgage.
It's,
it's,
it's a 30 year mortgage.
So these are the years,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
blah,
up to year 30.
Okay.
Now suppose I happen to have a bond that pays a coupon of $8 every year.
And the interest rate,
let's say a 7%.
So it'd be the interest rate on the mortgage.
But let's say the interest rate,
the economy is 7% and the bond however,
is a premium bond or the bond is paying 8% every year.
Now this is a mortgage,
not a,
okay.
Uh,
this is a mortgage.
So what does this mean?
Yeah.
See,
the mortgage pays eight every year until the very last year where it's still
paying eight.
Okay.
So it's not paying 108 is just paying eight every year.
So it's not a coupon bond.
It's a mortgage.
A mortgage pays the same amount every year until the end.
So if this were a coupon bond,
the last payment would be 108.
And of course the thing would be a tremendous,
uh,
it would be a premium bond because the interest rates only seven cause it would
pay a higher coupon of eight and 108 at the end.
But you'll see I'm not paying 108 at the end.
I'm only paying eight at the end.
So the question is,
the first question is,
what is the,
um,
you know,
what is the present value of this bond?
So I could take eight divided by 1.07 plus eight divided by one point over seven
squared plus all the way eight over one players Oh seven to the 30th power and
figure out that number.
But a much better way of doing it is by backward induction.
So what do I do?
I go to the end and I save this line is the,
is the remaining balance?
Well,
at year 30 there'd be no more payments of the bond.
So what's left?
The present value of what's left is obviously zero.
Now,
what is the present value of what's left at time 29?
Well,
the only thing I'm going to get is I'm going to get this payment at time eight
right over there.
All right,
I'm going to get this eight right there.
And so the present value of eight at 7% interest,
you know,
is one,
is 7.47 I mean 7% interest.
Okay?
So,
uh,
how did I figure that out?
I just said take that payment on the right and discounted by 7% so it's 7.47
now,
what's the present value here?
We'll here you're going to get two things.
What are you going to get?
You're going to get a coupon paint,
so when you're at the end,
just after the payment in year 28 what's the present value of what's left?
You're going to get a payment in year 29 of $8 you're also going to get one in
year 30 but you don't care about that.
You just know that the value in year 29 is the payment,
the coupon you get in year 29 plus the present value in year 29 of what's left.
The PV at time t,
I can just put a t here,
Pv at time.
T is the coupon you get at time.
T plus one plus the present value at time.
T plus one divided by the interest rate at time t.
Okay.
So all I have to do is take eight plus 7.47 and discount that by 7% and that
gives me the present value as of time.
Uh,
28 so if I go back to time 26 I say,
well how do I figure out the present value at time 27 I as time 27 I say,
well,
I'm going to get eight at time,
28 but the present value at that time,
just after I've made that,
after that payment is 14.4 so I take 22.4 and discounted by 7% and I get about
21 okay.
So that's how I can work backwards and figure out the present value today.
Now in mortgages,
this number is very interesting.
It's called the remaining balance.
Okay.
Which we'll see in a second.
But anyway,
that number you can calculate it every t it's just the PVT worked backwards from
the end.
So it's a very simple calculation and it tells you the present value of the
bond.
Okay.
Of that 8% coupon till you're 30 and no principal at the end.
Well,
the mortgage has to pay a coupon of 8% that uh,
you know,
that gives a hundred because the,
the,
if there were no uncertainty and there are no prepayments or anything,
no uncertainty,
the,
the bank giving the coupon is not going to give you money unless its present
value is equal to a hundred so they're going to be willing to pay,
they're going to ask you to pay a coupon.
Okay?
So now you see,
what have I done over here?
This is beach 26 minus B 30.
So the original face was supposed to be a 100 but the present value,
Volvo's payments is only a 99.
Okay.
And so there's a gap here of 0.72 and the square of the gap is that,
and we want to,
the square,
the gap is there and we want to minimize that.
So we're going to find the,
the payment every period solver.
Okay?
So I want to minimize be 32 minimized by choosing be 29 she looks good.
That's the first payment.
Okay.
And all the other payments are said to be equal to that,
to minimize that difference.
Uh
Oh,
be 29 is the first payment.
So why didn't this work too?
Yeah.
Is that what I did?
Okay,
so here's a,
that's the thing.
And then this,
Oh,
here,
why hired wire that in?
Okay,
so I didn't want to do that.
So that's got to be equal to what's left equal.
Left.
Uh,
okay.
So here I got,
I'm going to hire this and,
okay,
so that's good.
So let's try the same thing now.
So two olds that I have you guys tools.
Okay.
So being 32 is when I'm minimizing bead.
29 is the first payment and all the others have been set equal to it.
And if I solve,
okay.
All right,
let's drag the first payment is that year one,
right?
So it should be,
oh see,
29 thank you.
Yeah,
I'm not,
that's why I'm confused.
Okay.
See,
29 thanks.
Okay.
Tools.
Okay,
so,
so what are those?
Just look at this a second.
So that's what I've hardwired in.
Okay,
so format,
nope.
Tools solver.
[inaudible] 32 subject to see 29 as he was told me 20 times.
See 29 and now,
so all of,
okay,
so now we did it.
Okay,
so we got the right payment to make the balance exactly equal to 100 okay,
so that's how a mortgage works.
You have to find the payments such that if you take the present value of that
same coupon payment forever,
it's just going to be worth a hundred which is that number.
And how do you figure out the coupon payment?
Well,
you do it by backward deductions.
Figure out the present value.
You do it by backward induction.
Okay?
But it's just as we did,
but one,
we've gotten a lot of information.
We've gotten this number at every period.
So by doing it by backward induction,
instead of just doing,
you know,
the long exponential calculation,
by doing it by backward induction,
we produced the present value at every time in the future.
Now that's an incredibly important number in mortgages.
It's called the remaining balance.
Why is that such an important number and mortgages?
This will play a very key role.
And the rest of the course.
What is the remaining balance and why is it so important?
Does anyone know how a mortgage works?
Yup?
Okay.
Now we'd be able to sell it for but a little bit but close.
So when the bank gives you a mortgage,
it says,
okay,
so how did mortgages work?
It used to be in the old days that the mortgages were coupon bonds.
They pay eight eight,
eight,
eight eight 108 okay.
And then what would happen is just before the 108 payment,
everyone would default.
So in the depression,
the people defaulted where people would default to just before their big
principle payment.
So bankers got wise after the depression,
they said,
well that's a terrible thing to do.
We should make the payment be constant.
Okay.
And that way there's no reason for the guide to default right at the end.
And we're not going to get stuck with $100 it's not paid.
So it's constant.
But of course if it's constant,
that means the present value of what's left is going down all the time.
Okay.
So that's why this number is going down all the time.
You know,
if it's 108 at the end,
that's why the present value would stay the same.
So it's going down all the time.
Okay.
So that's uh,
that's why it's called an amortizing mortgage.
It's because what's left in the mortgage is getting smaller all the time.
Okay.
So a mortgage is paid,
a fixed rate mortgage pays the same coupon every year.
The present value of what's left therefore must be going down every year.
And that's why it's called amortizing.
And they,
bankers wanted that to happen because that way their risk is going down every
year.
Every year the house is presumably still worth 120 or whatever it was at the
beginning.
And the amount owed is getting lower and lower.
So the bankers are feeling more and more secure every year because the houses
backing a smaller and smaller loan.
Or to put it another way,
if you're uncertain about what the price of the house will be in the future,
you want to make sure that what is old is going down in the future.
So you don't,
you know,
if the price gradually goes down to the house,
what's owed is gradually going to go down.
Okay.
But the main reason why the number is so important is you have to realize the
purpose of a mortgages.
You take out a loan using the house as collateral.
If you don't make your payment,
they can take your house.
Well,
what happens if you want to move?
Okay,
if you want to move you,
you know you're going to sell the house.
The house is no longer collateral.
So if you want to move,
you have to undo the promise to the bank.
So if in your five,
just after you're making your payment of $8 and 5 cents in your five,
you decide to move,
you say to the bank,
you know,
I want to cancel the mortgage.
How much will they ask you to pay?
Well,
the remaining balance,
93 91 okay?
So that's the,
that's why this remaining balance and such an important number.
Okay?
So it allows people to leave their houses and pay off their mortgage by paying
off the remaining balance.
You wouldn't want them to pay a hundred if they laughed cause they've made
payments.
You notice that the payment here is $8 that's bigger than 7% right?
Cause if it's a coupon bond,
you'd pay seven all the way to the end and pay 107 that would have a present
value of a hundred if you're not paying the hundred at the end,
but just making a level payment all the way through the payment you have to make
every year better be more than seven.
So it's eight.
So this eight minus seven is sort of a what you're paying down of your mortgage,
right?
The interest is only seven.
You've paid eight.
That's why you owe less than a hundred you know you've paid a dollar six extra.
That's why you only owe 98 point 94 okay?
So every year you're paying part of your principle down.
That means it's amortizing and it means if you want to get out of the mortgage,
you can get out of it by paying less and less.
It means the,
the lender,
the mortgage lender is more and more protected by the house every year cause
what you owe is less and less.
Okay.
So that's how a mortgage works.
Any questions about that?
All right,
so those,
okay.
So what's the point?
The point is that by simple present value thinking,
you can start to understand the main instruments in the economy,
how mortgages work,
why they're called amortizing,
why the amount you have to pay to get out of your mortgage goes down every year
and exactly how much it goes down every year,
et cetera.
Okay.
But now I want to,
so we can do a lot more examples like that,
but I want to change,
shift the discussion now to a much bigger subject,
a subject of tremendous policy interest in the country.
Uh,
and uh,
namely social security.
What should we do about social security now it will turn out that you can
analyze the situation the same way we've just analyzed these bonds.
It's very simple to figure out what the problem is and what went wrong yet very
few people understand it,
including most of our politicians.
And I'm sorry to say a lot of our economists.
So what is,
so I want to describe now and the next class and a half the social security
problem and,
and how to,
you know,
how to resolve,
how to solve the problem,
but also how to understand the problem.
You can't figure out the right solution until you've understood what the problem
is.
Okay.
So,
uh,
were there any questions before I start this learning question?
I should have paused.
Are there any questions about the mortgage or present value or how present value
changes through time?
Okay,
so those ideas,
you know,
in marking to market,
those are very important ideas.
I think once you think about them,
not so hard,
I'm now going to take exactly those ideas and apply it to social security where
I bet where the public is totally baffled.
But all you have to do is apply the same thinking.
Okay.
So social security is supposed to be in a terrible crisis.
That's what they always tell you.
Um,
it was a big campaign issue in 2000.
You probably were too young to remember that,
but there were three debates between Gore and Bush in which Gore grimaced and
you know,
and uh,
everybody thought he wasn't a good guy and so they voted for Bush and he was
mostly grimacing about social security and a then in 2000,
well,
okay,
I'll get to the future.
So anyway,
they,
in those debates,
three mistakes were made.
Um,
so Bush argued that the returns on social security were disastrously low.
He said the whole program is in a terrible crisis and um,
we've got to privatized to save the system.
Okay.
Um,
how did they get into the crisis while it wasn't clear exactly how it got into
the crisis,
but,
you know,
it seems like the baby boomers had something to do with it.
They're all getting old and they're going to have to get these huge social
security payments and uh,
that's why we're in the crisis because the baby boomers are getting old.
It's all my fault and then they are my generation's fault.
Then the third mistake was Gore said,
well,
it's impossible to privatized.
Privatized means take the money that your parents are paying and social security
and that you'll start to pay instead of putting it into the fund,
which is being used somehow,
you don't probably know exactly how,
instead of doing that,
take that money and say it's the taxpayers' money.
It's your money.
You can put it in the stock market if you want.
So that's what Bush wanted to do.
Privatized social security.
Say your tax contributions should go into a stock market with your name on them.
And Gore said,
well that's impossible.
If you prioritize,
what are the old people today going to do?
Where are they going to get the payments?
You can't prioritize social security and take today's young tax contributions to
social security and say,
okay,
you young guys,
they're your money.
You can keep them in the stock market and at the same time pay the old retirees.
So Bush must not know what he's talking about.
So that also was wrong.
So those three things that social security,
uh,
you know,
is going to give terrible returns.
It must be,
it's wasting money.
Something's horribly wrong with it.
The only way to save it,
as to privatize it.
That's bushes,
main claim.
Blame it all on the baby generation.
That's everybody's claim.
And Gore saying you can't prioritize without screwing today's young.
That's all three of those things sound pretty convincing and yet they're all
three wrong.
Okay.
So I want to explain the system to you and help you understand it.
And then I have a policy recommendation you'll get next class,
which you know,
most people don't agree with.
So you probably won't either.
But uh,
but,
but I'll warn you when we get to a point that's controversial,
the point before,
I'm going to say it.
So everything I'm going to say in the first,
you know,
first 90 minutes is going to be uncontroversial.
Hold.
Not everybody knows it,
but I think is obviously it's just a matter of logic and then my conclusion
about what to do,
you can criticize it and I think it's a matter of logic too.
But I had met,
most people don't agree with it.
So now in 2005 bushes was,
if nothing else,
Bush was tremendously consistent.
So,
you know,
whatever he told you he was going to do,
no matter how wrong headed it was,
he did it.
So he said in the debates that he wanted to privatize social security,
and sure enough,
he kept his word.
He launched a huge program.
That's how he started right after the 2004 election is first initiative you
might remember was we've got to privatize social security.
Went on a 60 day 60 city tour to kick off his second term.
Okay.
So after the 2004 election,
privatizing social security was a huge issue in the 2008 election.
It was still a big issue.
Mccain said sort of what Bush said,
I want young workers to be able to,
you know,
if they choose to take part of their own money,
which is their taxes,
you know,
their money that's getting taxed and put into social security.
I want them to have their own account and put it into the stock market with
their name on it.
And Obama said he's totally against that.
Okay.
Now after that,
that was 2008.
Recently,
of course,
the,
the public has,
uh,
made another mistake.
And so everybody's saying now,
oh,
the financial crisis,
you know,
we better not talk about social security more anymore.
Nobody's talking about social security.
Um,
you know,
they're saying,
well,
could you imagine what would have happened had we privatized?
And you know,
as Bush wanted us to do in the stock market collapsed,
everybody would have lost all their money.
What a disaster that would have been.
It would have ruined the,
uh,
ruined the old.
Okay.
The sound's pretty persuasive,
you know.
So Krugman wrote a column saying,
you know,
a bullet dodged.
What would have happened if Bush had succeeded?
We all,
all the old people would be broke now.
And Robert Rice who was,
you know,
in the Clinton administration,
sorta more or less,
said the same thing.
That would be a disaster.
Um,
now the Obama administration,
by the way,
hasn't stopped talking about social security.
So their director,
he was,
he's the director of the White House Office of the budget.
So this is an incredibly important position.
Peter Orszag,
he's the son of a,
there's a math professor here or Zog his father.
So he said,
so he's a friend of mine,
the son,
he said,
uh,
you know,
one healthcare reform is in place.
The US can then focus on other important things,
especially social security.
So Obama wants to do something about it.
He just doesn't want a privatized.
So it's a big problem and everything everybody says about it seems plausible.
Now what,
just to continue along the plausibility of it.
So Bush says,
you know,
what he really wants to do is,
and why private accounts or a better thing is that if you put the money in
private accounts,
it can grow.
You can get a greater rate of return than the current system,
which is terrible.
If you are a young person,
you'll be able to,
you know,
make some,
uh,
you know,
by putting your tax,
social security tax money aside in a private account,
you'll be able to get a better rate of return on your money than the government
could get you on your money.
So why would you just want to give it to the government?
It's for your retirement and you'll be able to pass that money along to your
children and grandchildren.
You know,
if you want at the end.
And Best of all the money's yours and the government can't take it away.
Okay?
So that's what four says.
He said many times.
So there's one sense in which he's right.
So let's look at the returns people got on social security.
Now,
what is the return?
We know what the rate of return is.
How do they calculate it?
You can go back to people born starting in 1878 right?
Social Security,
as you'll see in a second,
I'll give you the history began in 1939 so these people in 1878,
you know,
they're in there.
So you know there's 60 you know,
when social security's beginning,
um,
my,
my arithmetic is right?
So they're just being,
you know,
they're 60 at that point.
So you can look at all these people and you can say for every generation in the
past,
you can say,
how much money did they pay when they were young?
They paid taxes.
So they got negative,
you know,
negative 12.4,
that's the tax rate and negative 12.4.
They did that a bunch of years when they are young.
And then they started getting payments when they were old,
you know,
24,
20,
something like that.
Those are the payments when they're old
and now you can,
so they're negative ones at the beginning and positive ones at the end you can
calculate the internal rate of return,
the number of the yield,
the thing that makes this present value zero.
We know how to do that.
We've done it.
So people have done this.
So there's a guy named Lemur.
Okay.
Uh,
at the Lima or Lemur from the Social Security Administration who did these
calculations prompted a little bit by me.
So I should say that a lot of the reason I got started thinking about this as I
got put on a presidential panel,
um,
to study social security reform,
uh,
and the Clinton administration and every Democrat was matched with Republicans.
So the two chairman,
one Democrat,
one Republican,
all the way along there was Democrat and Republican.
And after Bush got elected,
all the Democrats got kicked off the committee.
But anyway,
so the,
so in,
in any case,
the,
uh,
here are the rates of return for people who are old.
When the program began,
they got sensational rates of returns,
you know,
40% 30% incredible rates of return as the generations,
get younger and younger,
uh,
the returns go lower and lower and they're down now to 2%.
You know,
these are forecasted,
these rates of returns.
And so,
you know,
you,
let's see,
you're 20,
say something on average.
So you're born and it's,
you know,
it's,
you're born in 1990,
something like that.
So,
or around there,
so the uh,
here's your rate of return.
It's a down here,
right?
It's 2%.
It's let you know and there is a blown up.
It's under 2%.
So these are the people from 1924 to 2002.
So you're right at the end here.
That's your rate of return blown up.
You can only expect one and a half or 2% so George Bushes,
right?
The rate of return on social security is terrible.
If you look at the taxes that you put in and you look at the benefits that you
can expect to get,
your generation's getting totally screwed.
Okay,
so now if you look historically,
this was done in 1994 so the numbers a little bit,
uh,
it's not quite as dramatic,
but it hasn't changed as much as you think from money put in the stock market
between 26 and 2004 that's before the crash of 29 the crash.
So I should've gotten the number after the reason crash.
It doesn't change that much.
Before the crash of 29,
you looked at keeping your money in the stock market,
just leaving it there for all that time after inflation,
you'd get 9.1% return on treasury bonds,
you get 2.7% return.
And yet on social security,
you're going to get under 2% okay?
So George Bush says,
look,
put it in the stock market.
Get 9% okay,
we had a little disaster here,
but a,
so maybe it's 7% put it in the stock market.
Get 7% why be satisfied with 2% there's something wrong.
We've got to prioritize.
Put an end to this.
Okay,
so all right,
so there seems to be something to what he's saying.
So now you look at what's going on with social security.
So what happens in social security?
I'm going to explain the whole history and how it works here.
What happens is you pay taxes,
12.4% tax.
You probably know that everybody's paying taxes on the money they make and then
their benefits that are being paid.
Now the benefits are not,
there's a formula for benefits,
which doesn't have anything to do with the amount of taxes being paid.
So at the present time,
the taxes are bigger than the benefits.
So where does the extra money go?
It goes into the social security trust fund.
So here's the social security trust fund,
which is now round 2 trillion,
which is going to keep growing because contributions are going to be bigger than
benefits until 2020 or so.
And at that point,
contributions,
you know,
that's the baby boom generation.
That's me retiring.
So,
or you know,
a little later in my case.
But anyway,
the baby,
maybe we'll Jenner and facts and someone yelled,
professor,
it's out here somewhere.
Anyway,
so do you know,
so anyway,
my generation's going to start retiring here and then the benefits.
So we're going to be not working,
not paying taxes,
but we're collecting benefits and there's so many of us that the benefits are
going to be less than the taxes and the trust funds going to go down and down
and down.
And the New Year,
2030 a little bit more than 2030 the trust fund is going to go to zero.
And then after that the taxes are still going to be a smaller than the benefits.
And so what's going to happen,
there'll be no money to pay these people and there's going to have to be a big
drop and what people are getting.
So it looks like the system is not only paying a horrible rate of return,
it doesn't even look like it's,
you know,
it's an,
I'm going to pay,
it's going to run out of money and go broke in 2040.
So it seems like a total a disaster.
Okay.
So that's the setting of the question.
George Bush said,
it's a disaster.
It looks at first glance like a disaster.
The newspapers tell you all the time,
it's a disaster.
How did it get to me so bad?
And what should we do about it?
All right?
Now it's going to turn out that by using the concept of present value,
it can be very simple and straight forward to understand.
And it's going to be the exact opposite of what everybody seems to be saying.
So I,
uh,
I'm gonna play you a clip next time of Roosevelt announcing the social security
program.
And this lady behind him is Frances Perkins,
the first woman to ever be the,
uh,
in the cabinet.
And she played a tremendous role in shaping social security.
So after,
uh,
Roosevelt started social security in 2004,
um,
I'm wondering whether I really have time to do this.
So I'll just say this.
So Roosevelt started the program in 2000 in 1938 39,
he started the program in 38 39.
It was one of the cornerstones of the new deal.
It's an incredibly famous program and it seems to be incredible trouble.
So we need to find out and get to the bottom of why that is,
and then we'll start doing that next class.